[Music]  another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do administer spankings to doctor  rights if dr rights is found to be in  violation of any foundation rules or  regulations there are existing  disciplinary actions in place that  should be abided by dr bright is to be  reminded that corporal punishment is not  considered an acceptable method of  discipline in a professional environment  or anywhere else it doesn't matter if  his parents spanked him and he turned  out fine he did not turn out fine and he  is not dr rights's parent the hr  department is tired of dealing with this  and if it is not handled laura from that  department has said and i quote i'll  throw him out my office window and i'm  not joking she's not joking cut it out